5 30 here it's Friday morning we do
start with breaking news a person shot
and killed this morning by North Las
Vegas Police and right now streets
around the scene are blocked we have our
Lauren negretti joining us live from the
scene this is near la Madre and Alan
Lorna what have we learned so far this
morning
that's right you guys yes this is a
fatal officer involved shooting what
North Las Vegas PD told me is that this
all happened shortly before 1am during a
traffic stop officers made contact with
the driver during that interaction the
driver pulled out a gun from their glove
box officers reacted in two and two
officers fired the driver was pronounced
dead at the scene as you can see behind
me there is still that traffic excuse me
that police tape restricting traffic in
the area we've seen an officer Milling
about over there we see we still see
about four cop cars in the area and I've
saw I've seen some drivers kind of
coming through and being redirected
coming through this area we are working
to get some more information for you
this is an ongoing investigation North
Las Vegas Police Bureau will be leading
the investigation for now live in North
Las Vegas Lauren negretti 8 News Now